[Applause]
[Music]
it's cause for celebration as wedding
bells are ringing on the Jersey Shore
let's take the old memories Angelina and
throw them out and like now I'm ready to
create new ones
et can exclusively confirm that Jersey
Shore star Angelina Pavan ik is married
and we have your first look at the
newlyweds first photos as husband and
wife
Suvarna tied the knot to Chris Lehren
gira in a Wednesday ceremony at the Parc
Chateau estate and Gardens in where
other than the Jersey Shore Jersey just
amazing all around we're here like we're
in our own home right now and it
wouldn't be a Guido party unless
Angelina's Jersey Shore fam was in
attendance this is like amazing Jenni
JWoww Farley Nicole Polizzi aka Snooki
and Deena Cortese II joined the
celebration as bridesmaids and Vinny
buena Nino Ronnie ortiz-magro DJ Pauly D
and Mike the situation Sorrentino were
dressed to the nines posing for pics
with the blushing bride Angelina's
gorgeous strapless gown was created by
castle couture and her husband for a
custom suit by croco suits as for the
party the newlyweds and guests enjoyed
an elegant all-white decor reception
that included a customized martini bar
and a massive cake said to be almost the
size of Angelina back in 2018 Angelina
dish 2 et about planning her special day
I want local I want more intimate like
you know more I want it smaller I don't
want a huge thing but yeah I want it to
be like close family and friends and you
know maybe some of these guys will come
you know you never know and yeah that's
really what we're planning on doing
right now she also talked about
introducing her then fiance Chris to the
rest of the Jersey Shore cast
I've already sat him down and let him
know the things that I've done already
and you know what they might say and
just to be you know put the seat belt on
because things gonna need that he's
gonna need a seat belt buckle up
[Music]